a friendly match in the backyard of the
National Museum in the Yemeni city of
Aden the professional players from Al
Talal are taking on an amateur third
division side this dusty patch of land
is all the long-established Club has
left the stadium has been partly
destroyed and is now in a restricted
military area and occupied by soldiers
the league in Yemen stopped operating
when the war broke out
the only chance professional players get
to play football is in friendlies like
this the guys are not as fit as they
used to be because we don't train
regularly and because they have no
competitive games they only train three
or four times a month and the club only
pays them pocket money they struggle to
make ends meet just like the majority of
people in Yemen unemployed I was able to
live well from football but that's all
gone now I don't have enough anymore
it's really tough for me I have to think
about doing something else to earn money
maybe I'll join the army
there are many different factions
operating in southern Yemen with
different goals someone to separate
state in the south
others are fighting Houthi rebels in the
north the country is divided and
football is divided - there is only
informal contact with people in the
north of the country especially in those
areas that are controlled by the Houthi
rebels but we still have a joint
National Team works
but the national team has not played in
Yemen for years because of the security
situation it has to play all its matches
abroad Sampson in Aden is one of the
lucky sides to still have a stadium and
fans still watch the games even if they
are only friendlies I'm so happy to
watch the games I feel great to be here
with the young guys and to support them
Yemen's professional league may no
longer exist but the people's love of
football remains for many in Yemen
football provides a much-needed escape
from the brutal reality of civil war